[موسيقى]
تتسلل عبر مياه الأمازون
كائنات نهرية عملاقة
يبلغ حجمها ثلاثة أمتار ويصل وزنها إلى 200
كيلوغرام ، وهي واحدة من
أكبر أسماك المياه العذبة في العالم
[الموسيقى]
وكانت على مدى أجيال
مصدرًا رئيسيًا للغذاء في هذه الأجزاء
ومع ذلك ، مع نمو المجموعات السكانية وتحديثها ،
وقعت الأنواع ضحية
للصيد الجائر
وأصبحت شبه منقرضة في مناطق معينة ، أصبح
صيد الأرابيما الآن غير قانوني في
البرازيل
ما لم يتم القيام به بشكل مستدام كجزء من
برامج الحفظ المجتمعية.
وضع هذه البرامج في
مكانها ، حيث يعمل عالم الأحياء في مصايد الأسماك
منذ أكثر من عقد
للمساعدة في حماية الأسماك
بالنسبة له ، ويتلخص ذلك في تمكين المجتمعات
المحلية والقادة من اتخاذ إجراءات على سبيل المثال
حراسة المناطق المحمية من الشقوق غير القانونية
وإغلاق البحيرات المتصلة بالنهر إلى الصيد
والصيد
وإدخال الإدارة
الحذرة لصيد الأسماك
هو أمر غاية في الأهمية  مثير للاهتمام لأن
هذا النموذج في الواقع
بسيط للغاية في الواقع
لفترة طويلة تم استبعاد الأشخاص
من منظور الحفظ
لكنهم في الواقع يلعبون قاعة مهمة
للغاية للحفاظ على الغابة التي
نتحدث عنها عن تغيير نموذجي
يجب أن يعني الحفاظ على حياة أفضل
بالنسبة للسكان المحليين
في السنوات العشر الماضية ، يقول إن كل ذلك
ساعد في زيادة أعداد الأرابيما
أربعة أضعاف أثناء حماية
الحياة البرية الأخرى في الأمازون ،
هل نتحدث عن نجاح أه في
هذه الحالة
بدأ الحفظ منطقيًا الآن
يقول السكان المحليون
إننا بحاجة إلى حماية البيئة نحن
بحاجة إلى حماية
الطبيعة لأن المزيد من التنوع البيولوجي يعني
حياة أفضل يقول Campos silva إن الفوائد
تتجاوز مجرد الحفاظ على
الدخل المتزايد من
الصيد المستدام يتم استثماره في البنية التحتية
والرعاية الصحية للنساء أيضًا قادرات على
كسب الدخل من
خلال أدوار أكبر في إدارة arapaima ،
لذا فهذه سمكة حقيقية  التغيير
الذي كان يشجع على تحول اجتماعي ضخم
في الأمازون المحفوظة من
الانقراض وبالتالي حماية سبل العيش والمجتمعات
عبر الأمازون